好 李卓总 很久没见 很高兴啊
很高兴
今天能够在香港你能接受我的这个邀请
来做个访谈
对
这是一次非常重要的访谈
因为呢 一直以来呢
咱们经历了很多很多的故事
对
你和比亚迪之间 甚至包括和我个人
那么这是个难得的复盘
对
对于比亚迪而言啊
你把比亚迪的故事
对
你不仅仅是
一个重要的投资者
你更是我们的老朋友
嗯
而且呢
也是我们比亚迪的发展 资本市场
以及公司发展以来呢
重要的参与者和见证者
也是非常多重要节点的建议者
所以说呢
我们想呢
给您花点时间
嗯
我们来聊一聊在过去
整理整理思路
嗯
回顾一下过去
对
展望一下未来
是
您还记不记得您第一次
对
什么时候听到比亚迪这三个名字
是什么样的场景
对
你知道了比亚迪
你当时知道的比亚迪
你的第一印象是啥
这个算起来得差不多有25年了大概啊
嗯
大概2000年初
我在阅读一本trade magazine啊
就是一个技术性的一个刊物啊
那么读到了一则消息
就是一家中国的公司呢
现在开始在做这个rechargeable
这个battery
给这个
嗯
给这个cell phone啊
当时的去报道呢
连这个像Motorola什么
当时Motorola是最大的这个
如日中天的
如日中天
根据那个杂志的报道啊
在使用这家中国的公司
当时我也没有太注意这个名字
但是这个中国公司这件事呢
就引起了我的这个注意
嗯
因为在这个之前呢
我刚刚在研究一个案例
一个投资的案例呢
美国的一个很著名的这个battery公司呢
想去使用这个铃电池呢
来去做rechargeable
因为那个时候的battery都是一次性的
对
那个时候能够使用这个rechargeable的
只有几家日本公司
对
所以这件事就对我非常的有印象
也记住了这个公司
2000年
对
那么过了两年呢
这个我就发现这家公司就开始上市了
嗯
然后确实有报道这个Motorola
真的在使用这家公司
那么我查到呢
正好他在美国有一个
就在Motorola边上的芝加哥呢
有一个这个办事处
所以我就直接打电话
哈哈哈
这位太厉害了
啊这个接电话的这个呢
就是Stella
那个时候我就不知道他有这么重要
哈哈哈
所以我们就聊了一下
聊了一下呢
这个我是对技术问题很有兴趣啊
对他怎么解决的这个问题非常的有兴趣
他说那好
我们创始人对这个技术非常的了解
可能我们电话之后很快
他说他会到这个芝加哥来
他说我可以安排你去见一下
哎我说太好了
哈哈哈
大概这个电话过后不久
王总就来了
那是上来室之后
哎对了
对大概秋天的样子吧
秋天样子
然后我呢就飞过去了
我们呢就是就是安排了他
这个临走的时间
就在这个机场边上
一个很小的一个hotel里
我们原来他给我安排大概就
见个半个小时一个小时了解一下情况
但是我跟王总的这个一见如故
一聊聊了好几个小时
哈哈哈
就把时间也都忘掉了
所以这一次呢是让我真正的了解了这个
比亚特殊的地方
所以在那个之后
很快呢我就决定
开始真正的了解这家公司了解了以后呢
我们买了第一份股份
哈哈哈
现在已经23年了
这个这些股份都还在
哈哈哈
那当然当然我我我非常清楚
日子过得也很快
那是02年7月份上的市吗
对
然后你应该是秋天左右
跟王总见面你就
不久
就就不久
我的是97年创建的公司
98年的开始这个
开始转的
对对对
那个时候规模还是蛮小的
应该你是仓位比较重
跟今天比金额不大
对对对但是仓位还可以
是的
我印象是可能有12点的仓位
对
因为我们的基本的风格相对来说比较集中
然后持有的时间比较长
但是去选那些比较特殊的公司
我还是记忆很深刻的
您和一般的投资人不太一样
后来我陪王总和您也见过多次
每一次呢像我这种财务背景的人
基本就插不进嘴
一个小时呢甚至两个小时
你和王总都是在不断的去讨论战略
对
产品、技术
其实可能财务的数字呢
只是轻描淡写的去了解一下
主要是也是了解财务结构
而并不是过于均匀于冰冷的财务数据
这一点呢也是一直让我很感慨
也学习到很多真正的价值投资
应该是这样的一个过程
对
那么王总当时留给您是什么样的一个印象
对,印象非常的深
我的三十几年的一直研究的是
什么样的企业能够成功
什么样的企业会失败
企业发展的过程
商业的历史
这中间呢就离不开这些特殊的企业家本身的特质
那一般的这个企业呢都是创世人的这个延伸
至少在早期的时候是这样
带有很强的创世人的痕迹
我们从第一次开始聊天啊
一直到现在啊
过了二十几年
每年都会有很深入的交流
那么王总这几这些年呢
一直没有变化
在一些根本的方面
第一呢
他是确实是原创性的
那么马斯克后来用这个词叫第一性原理思维
我叫他这个科学性的思维
物理学的思维
用第一性思维来这个思考战略问题
用工程师的这个思维方式来解决问题
落地执行
同时呢这个拥有这个坚定的这个意志
不为任何艰难
也敢于成功
同时呢
他对于一个商业的这个利益有关者呢
始终抱有受托人的精神
受托人的责任
无论是对股东还是对员工
还是对经销商还是对客户
这样的一个这个combination呢
其实是很rare的
很难找到
这个我当时就很惊讶了
他在整个这个上市
这个公司在上市之前没有过BC
他承诺给所有人的股份呢
其实一直都是由他来去直接弄
所以他没有BC实际上是没有改进去的
但是他的这个股份一直在降低
一直在给大家
那么这样的就使得我们很容易呢
去信任他
一起去面对各种各样的困难挑战
所以我这二十几年里面啊
我们经历过无数的困难
无数的挑战
无数的这个艰难的时刻啊
但是我从来没有怀疑过呢
我们的利益和这个创选的利益
是完全一致的
他的所有的公司的各种各样的这个商业
全都在同一家公司里
外面没有
那么在分红之前
他除了这个基本的工资之外
也没有别的收入
他全副的经历
所有公司的这个IP
他全部的创业都在同一个地方
我们和王主席呢
永远在一边
永远在一起
所以这样的一个这个结合啊
真的是一个非常了不起的结合
用第一性的思维来思考战略问题
用工程师的思维来解决实际的问题
坚韧不拔
永不言歪
直到成功
用颂托人的精神和责任
让所有人信任
愿意跟你一起去走过千山万水
直到成功
所以这种起家呢
是在任何一个时代都是凤毛民调
一旦发现了之后
要值得终身的珍惜
一定要抓住他
一定要就是他了
对吧
是的我也很感慨
就说王总呢
在比亚迪眼中
或者在我李奇的眼中
一定是神一样存在的
一个也是我这一辈子
能够给我个人创造人生价值的
这么一个贵人领路人
但是我也很感慨
其实那个时候王总才36岁
对
你也是36岁
我们两个同年
差两个月
都是36岁
刚才你提到了
其实商业的本质
说明了王总他已经看透了
比如关于分享
他一直以来对于
整个团队的基地和利益分配
他是非常非常的大度和公平
而且是有长期考量
因为我在他身边这个岗位
我一定是知道王总的长期考量
对于上下游的各种利益关系
他非常清楚他的责任和担当
其次他又有韧劲
和又有这种工程师的这种专业的能力
和打不垮的精神
所以这是比亚迪的内核
这也是比亚迪
第一次见到他
就强烈的感受到前面那几种特质
后面他的意志决心抗压的能力
还有他的受托人精神
他的受托人精神是在后面
慢慢地感受的越来越深
而且越来越强化
但是他的第一性原理的思维方式
他用工程师的方式解决问题的能力
我们在第一次见面的时候
几个小时长谈
我就感触非常的深刻
这一点从始至终都是这样
王总的性格就是永不满足
是
这个时候您可能
2002年7月份上市的时候
我们只是坐着插着过白锤
而且是个小公司
但是是个很有特点的公司
而且王总是个有特点的企业家
但是2003年一开年
王总就给资本市场炸了一个大雷
王总要进入汽车产业
收购青川汽车
股价暴跌
我们比亚迪和资本市场的关系
王总当时说
您当时已经是投资人了
您的第一反应是什么
我没有什么特别的反应
因为用第一性原理思考的人
他的商业是没有边界的
他的边界就是不违反科学的原理
不违反物理学的基本原则都可以做
而落地的时候是要用工程师思维
所以我的最关心的问题
是怎么做到这点
这个生意是不是很好的生意
这是很好的生意
他的基本的想法
这个我们就不断的去交流
不断的去学
这个行业本身是一个巨大的行业
毫无疑问
中国公司有很多的优势
这也是毫无疑问
这个是一个特别困难的商业
而且是一个著名的粉厂
著名的粉厂
对
掩埋了无数的线路
当时其实中国很多公司都要进军汽车
最后都没下去了
包括秦川
包括收购的秦川
秦川他这个例子
这是我的基本的反应
我是想了解更多的怎么把它做好
有什么不同的方式去做
那么王总其实做收购秦川的公司
要做汽车
但是从一开始
实际上他是已经考虑到了
这个电池本身的发展
将来是有可能支撑更大的动力
李电池的发展本身
已经开始出现了一个曲线
这个曲线是可以最后导致
它能够便宜和有足够的动力
去支撑一个很大的载体
就是汽车
这就是第一性思维的使然
但是这个过程要落地
是一个很漫长
需要工程师的思维
去一点点把它做起来
那么他的想法
是先把传统车做汇 做通
然后在时机成熟的时候
把电池成熟的时候
再叠加上去
来触动这个变化
那么在这个时候
其实我同时在和Tesla接触
那个时候的Tesla
还不是Elon Musk
还没有完全入主
他是一个投资人
那个时候的创始人叫Martin
所以他们也在考虑
是不是我也去
我有几个朋友
是他大的投资人
他们也想让我去加入
所以我也在了解整个这个过程
可以说就是说
比外地和Tesla
几乎是同时
在两个不同的国家
都在探索电动车的
颠覆传统车的可能性
当然历史最后的情况
就是这两家公司
真正的引导了这次革命性的变化
那么到了05年
比亚迪的第一款车F3
燃油车出来
应该讲是一炮打红了
用燃油车来支持着
比亚迪的整个电动车的
持续的研发投入
但是说实在的
那个时候比亚迪还是多条腿走路
电池仍然在做
汽车在投入
零部件是代工产业
也开始起来
从资产负债表的角度
当时还是非常的
负担非常重
研发又是王总
非常坚持的方向
在那个时间点到了07年
当时资产负债表如果
我们还记得应该讲
已经到了一个崩在悬崖边上的
当时的诺基亚我记得非常清楚
想给你代工业务
但是又怕你撑不住
在那个背景下
我们开始了比亚迪电子的分拆上市
对比亚电子分拆上市
当时也是您在支持着王总
去要把他分拆要求母子
比亚迪电子的分拆是个痛苦的过程
但是我们还好
就是说我们也坚定了
这个世界一定会溃增
那些正直且努力的人
所以我们在07年底
我们赶上个末班车
最后一秒咱们上的车
2007年12月份
筹集了足够的资金
募了67亿港币
这样子让2008年的金融危机来临的时候
比亚迪依然平稳度过
而且还可以持续大力研发
所以08年坦白说对比亚迪而言
我们没有感觉到什么叫做金融危机的寒冬
而且08年我们还发生了一个高官时刻的事
08年您介绍巴菲特入口比亚迪了
我想请问您
为什么要把巴菲特介绍给比亚迪
您当时是怎么想的
以及为什么是08年
不是07年
也不是09年
我们整个发展的过程
就是边界不断在拓宽
不断在重新定义制造边界的过程
做了很多
但是这些其实都是要让我们能够
在一个过渡时间
持续地把这个电池的研发继续做下去
然后对汽车的基本的制造能力继续掌握
还是在去思考着有一天
这个行业会发生革命式的范式的变化
那个时候我们要处在最合适的状态下去做这件事
所以这些其实都是互相去作用的
到了08年09年金融危机的时候
我们其实处的位置还可以还不错
但是整个世界经济从美国的视角看
确实是面临着崩溃的这样的可能性
包括其实我们的股价
所有公司的股价
整个中国市场的股价
我们确实处在相对蛮好的位置
我一直还是希望在整个中国发展的过程中
尤其是像比亚迪这样特殊的发展过程中
我们要真正的去走出一条前日没有走过的
真正的一条了不起的大路
我们还是要有一些特殊的能量输入
如果我们的研发
如果我们的制造能力逐渐地在往前推进
总有一天我们是有可能去颠覆这个行业的
我们要真正做到这点
需要很多很多的加持
一个很重要的加持
不仅是资本的加持
还是我们生意的加持
因为这些年我已经比较有信心了
对于王总还有公司还有我们未来的发展
各个方面都建立起越来越强的信心
这个跟股价没有什么关系
对公司本身的价值创造是完全相关的
所以我建立起来这样的信心
我也知道我们要再往下走
我们需要一些外力的协助
我们需要在生育上做得更好
而且我们当时受到打击最大
其实还是在生育上
如果在那一刻崩溃
我们所有的努力还有公司的潜能
就会被扼杀在摇篮里
但是公司本身这个时候的发展
已经完全具备了成为革命者的全部的陪抬
颠覆者的全部的陪抬
所以它的外界的压力
还有我们整个市场的perception
让股价和我们实际的能力
形成了一个巨大的落差
所以这个时候也为投资者
带来了一次非常好的机会
所以这个时候引入我信任尊重的投资者
就在价值上成为客家
那么因为这些年我和芒格先生
从03年04年结成了投资合伙人的关系
从此芒格先生成了我终身的粮食义友
又是商业上的合伙人
通过我的基金
其实芒格家族已经在那个时候
拥有比亚迪至少4年了
在这个过程中我也一直在介绍
比亚迪这家公司
它的梦想 它的能力
它不断拓展的边际
它将来面临的机遇
那么当时面临的状况
它的内在价值还有股价
还有其他的亚迪
就这些都形成一个共性
就在08年的时候
公司也需要这样的生意的加持
这个时候加持又是一个
投资比亚迪一个非常好的事情
价格和价值形成了巨大的过差
所以这个是一个共赢的事情
所以就在08年09年的时候
我开始去推动这件事情
那么当然我们也非常幸运
这件事情后来成为可能
让我们公司在比较短的时间
获得了全世界的关注
当它真正的具备了成为颠覆者的时候
它已经具备了这样的声誉
这个声誉又合上我们的
这个自身的能力
这个自身的能力在这不断的
到了节点的时候
就出现了一次巨大的爆发
这使得公司上了一个了不起的台阶
这个就是一个共赢的事情
对于Porsche是一个共赢的事情
对比亚迪是一个共赢的事情
对中国的资本市场也是一个共赢的事情
让世界第一次了解到
在中国正在发生的神奇性的
革命性的技术性的变化
这是一个特别奇妙的旅行对我来讲
因为一开始说巴菲特投比亚迪的时候
当你把这个消息传到我们这儿来的时候
其实从我个人内心里面
这怎么可能
后来我在巴菲特的股东大会里面的发言里面
也对王总以及对我们几位团队
比亚迪也是高度保密的
只有三四个人知道
包括我在内
也是高度评价
在这一个多月内我们并没有去炒作
我们的股价非常的平稳
没有变化
这也是一定程度上
也体现了这个团队是一个有职业操作的团队
咱们敲定那天开完电话会议
晚上当天我熬了个通宵
我准备协议准备发布会
然后第二天早晨我很早就答应了
国内的一个券商
他们来三四个投资人来比亚迪调研
我其实熬了整个通宵
但是我答应了他
我要接待我
第二天还是要去接待一下
王总还打电话给我
身体没问题吧
我说王总没问题
协议基本定了
咱们就看当天股价不移动就好了
这个deal就完成
然后我认真地接待
我接待完了这半个小时
他们也是参观工厂
我就对他们说
对不起
我的同事陪你去工厂
我还有一件重要的事情要处理
结果到了当天晚上
新闻出来
是巴菲特路公比亚迪
其中的一位投资人还是谁
把他给了记者
记者写到新闻上说
他们在接待比亚迪董秘李前说
我还有一个重要的事情接待
原来这件事情是巴菲特路公比亚迪
对对对
我们八块零四收的盘
八块钱的定价
当天礼拜一开盘十六
后来冲到了八十
所以这对我而言
是我人生的一个高光时刻之一
也是要感谢李路总
您创造了这个契机
没有我们共同的
这个不是我
您创造这个
新闻比亚迪值得投资
这也是双赢
双向奔赴
那么Mongo其实也一直评价您
他最好的投资就是您
然后在整个资本市场圈
毫无疑问
您是华人的投资巨匠
这就是大家公认的
包括也是我心理上的
但是也是我心理上的
对您的一个崇拜或者高度认可
但实际上这件事情
我觉得更有意义的是什么
你架起了中国和西方的桥梁
正是因为这一次投资
中国跟西方资本市场
尤其像巴菲特这种
如此伟大的投资公司
与中国企业之间的纽带的连接
甚至于我认为这个影响
远超过了这个挣钱本身
到今天比亚迪国际化
我们能够在海外
以两三年的时间
走完别人十年
甚至几十年的国际化的路
我个人认为也是与当时的入股
当时的入股让比亚迪
在全球声名雀起
也是有息息相关的
今天的我们走到全球
资本市场都知道BYD
多种原因
我相信这也是重要的原因之一
巴菲特入股之后
比亚迪声名雀起
股票从8块钱一把涨到80
一年的时间涨到80
成为了全世界或者说全香港
资本市场最受关注的那个量载
那么我们在09年10年的发展
也是大跨步的往前走
但是坦白地说
那个时候我们的步子有点大
到了1年王总在公司内部大会上
也开始反思
那时候我们遇到了种种的挑战
其实随意表开始出问题
其实盈利上有问题
从而也带来了投入有大
资产负债表也遇到挑战
尤其重要的是上下游的伙伴
客户受到了伤害
我们的F6等一系列的车型并不成功
我们的经销商我们的退网试电
王总也在反思我们过去三年
认为是个调整期
那我想您作为我们最坚实的投资者
在当时这几年的过程
你心里产生变化了吗
就这样我们关注的公司
是它的长期内在价值的变化
其实股价的变化对我们影响
确实不是太大
无论是它涨了十倍
还是后来跌了80%
其实我们既没有一股卖掉
也没有一股买下来
我们还是原来的基本人吃仓
但是这三年公司本身发生了很大的变化
一方面它在很多方面都高歌猛进
另一方面又在高歌猛进中犯下了一系列
可能这个行业都会犯的错误
就你回头来看
雅尼在这些年犯的错误
其实在过去这个行业
为什么是著名的坟场是有道理
其他的企业在它的发展不同的过程中
很多犯过类似的错误
也有很多失败
也有很多彻底消失
所以这个行业首先是充满了挑战的行业
但是我们很重要的一点
就是在整个拓展的过程中
其实我们一直想做的事
仍然是拓展我们对于车本身的理解
对它整个零部件的理解
对它规模化生产的把控
考虑的还是这个电池如果发展到足够的阶段
这场革命还是会发生
但是在这个过程中
我们有好多行业是要养未来的行业
互相的去养
但是在这个养的过程中
这个行业养别的行业就特别的困难
辛苦
而且充满了挑战和风险
那么在这三年里面
我们对这一点体会的尤其深刻
所以这个事给了我们很大的教训
但是确实也是成长中的烦恼
也是我们必须要经历的过程
我并没有觉得这个有什么特殊的地方
因为这样的错误
几乎所有的车企都经历过
那么经历不过去
这个坎过不去的就进入到坟场
过去的跨过去的
就会成为后来的伟大的公司
对我们的考验
其实还是能不能跨过这道坎
在这点上我们又回到原来的一直的信任
就是我相信我们的团队
我们相信我们很多的先天的优势
也相信我们学习的能力
我们其实这些年还有一点
大家还是保持了这个平常性
就是也不会把自己太当回事
无论别人怎么去评价你
至少我不认为我是什么神奇
我也不认为王总自己是多少神奇
我们该犯的错误都要犯
该要的学习都要学习
但是要坚持永远在错误中学习
最好是从别人的错误中学习
不要老在自己的错误中学习
这个代价比较大
但是犯了错误学习
面对现实然后永不言败
继续往前走
这是一个企业能够走下去的根本要求
我们不是去学习别人
我们是开拓者
后来学习的要容易多了
开拓者是很难的
你要制造一个不存在的市场
所以你一定要具备很多不同的能力
但是具备多少这个度很难把握
所以在这些问题上的探索
有的时候这个错误是必要的
这些代价是必须要付出的
每一个成功的企业都要经历
一系列的凤凰念牌
它不可能就一蹴而就了
所以我还是对你充满了感谢
也是您对我的人生充满了启发
我记得11年左右吧
我有点绷不住了
我对种种的失误我没有逃避
我没有放弃
我也在想公司要改变
要找解决办法
我不知道你还记得我到洛杉矶
当时你还在洛杉矶
我到你洛杉矶我到你办公室
咱俩也是深聊了两三个小时
可能那个时候我也年轻
我的表达相对更直接
我在找救命稻草
去希望能够让公司变得更好
那次聊天对我的人生是充满着
启发和重要意义的一次聊天
因为我得到了我的满意的答复
我得到了希望鼓励
您不断地在鼓励我
您就是用刚才讲的第一性原理
你也跟我讲你说李全
我见了非常多的中国企业家
来我这里交流
我中国的企业家
我这些最好的企业家们
我都熟悉
但是像王总如此有韧劲
对科学探索的无尽的渴望
如此有边界感的企业家不多
就冲着这一点
你相信比亚迪一定会越来越好
这是当时我们那两三个小时
你给我的最大的鼓励
我记忆非常的由心
后来在资本市场
因为当时您说到了
一个产业去复利一个产业
尤其拿汽车这个产业去复其他产业
而且王总的性格上又是非常的坚决
研发投入是不可以放弃的
不管我经营怎么样
今天还是这样
所以那几年我的压力也是比较大的
从12年上市A股上市
13年做点心债
14年闪电配售
15年融151的A股
而这一系列我和您交流的都是比较多的
也再次感谢你给我的鼓励
我要感谢你
感谢你在这个过程中
为资本市场培植耐心长期的投资者
对一个成长型的企业真的是至关重要
所以你在这么多年里面坚持做这件事情
做得很好
而且建立起别人对你的信任
做得非常的好
感谢
我也向你感谢
14年发生了一件有意思的事
有一天中午一点多钟
股价突然就莫名其妙的
百分之十几百分之二十几百分之三十几
我的桌上的电话我的手机
我就已经开始运过不过来了
当时也很有意思
非常多的投资者坚定的长期投资者
打电话问我那天跌到50%最低
一天跌50%
坚定的投资者常见的他就问我一句话
李前公司有问题没有
我给他们说公司没问题
他们就坚定的敢买了
但是其实我心里面也没底
因为资本市场股价的表现
不只是公司有没有问题
其实还有很多外在的环境
比如我第一时间我问王总
王总公司有没有什么事情我不知道的
王总跟我说李前没有
那我基本上就敢回答投资者
公司没有问题
紧跟着谣言四起
巴菲特要减车了
李璐要减车了
我当时坦白说我不知道你在哪
但是我不管
我不管是晚上几点了
我就给你打了个电话
您呢也很吵
您当时应该在国内
在飞机上
你跟我说李前我在飞机上
我说太好了你借过电话了
我说李璐总现在股价
你看看股价
股价怎么了
我说股价已经跌了百分之十四五十了
我说江湖在传
李璐总您在减持
当时您给了我一个坚定的回答
您说李前
一定不是我
第二我对公司充满信心
然后有了这个回答
我就敢于向资本市场去传递
第一公司没问题
第二李璐总没有减持
希巴拉也没有减持
我们是当天晚上
巴菲特这边早晨我们联系上了
知道了他没有动作
所以在第二天早晨的七点钟
王总和我召开了一个记者发布会
我们给市场澄清了
当天的股价呢
就涨回百分之三十
后来又回到了原来的位置
而且呢
我也再次表示感谢
您又买了三百多万股
因为您看到的是比亚迪的价值
您又继续支持了比亚迪
王总当时也非常的感慨
其实那个时候公司的经营情况
并不是说在已经出现拐点
当时您也是为了坚定您的信念
是坚定对比亚迪的信念
2020年我们后继爆发
当年发生两件事
第一个疫情
比亚迪发挥了我们的
中国制造最典型的高效
军团作战
我们的口罩
然后六月份退出来的汗
一炮大火
在这个过程中
在你跟王总有些什么样的交流
因为你也是王总的智勇
也是支持者和建议者
在那个关键的节点
你和王总的交流的状态是什么
19年底2020年初
这个也是一个特发的事情
我们最早口罩的起因
因为我们刚刚发生武汉的疫情之后
那个时候也是因为
我们看到这种需求非常的交集
所以我在美国发起了一个天使基金会
就是要在美国去动员
能够动员各种各样的人力物力财力
去支援武汉
那么当时我遇到的最大的挑战
就是我们买口罩买不着
买口罩变得很困难的一件事情
我到处去找
然后运力一开始发生各种各样的困难
一个一个的解决
但是解决了以后
其实我们钱也筹到
我自己也投入了很多钱
但是我们买不到
就买的很少
我们能买到的全部买来了
所以当时我跟王总正好在假期的时候在一起
这个时候我跟他谈了我们在做的这个事
他就问我最困难的什么地方
毒点节点
我跟他说口罩
这是我的最大的毒点
他说我来想一想办法
他这个当天晚上立刻让这个回去
动员所有的事业部
我们开会
我们开会了分工
这个事可以解决
当时实话我也很惊讶
但是确确实实在那个之后
慢慢的他就真的做起来了
这个时候又是芒果先生的帮助
那么我们就跟Costco建立起背书
也是用信誉来去背书
有这样的制造能力
这是一家了不起的公司
然后关键的是我们的美国的认证
还是做得比较完整
在中国已经开始使用
而且非常有这张口罩
所以我们第一笔大的订单
就是在Costco6000万口罩
所以这一下子
就让我们很多其他地方
因为有Costco
我们最早有芒果先生背书
有Costco的第一个订单
然后之后其他的
有各个地方的需求
全球都来了
一下子就抢
最后卖了在全球卖了几十亿口罩
所以这个过程
又是一个非常有趣的过程
又再次见证了第一比亚迪的制造能力
真的是无边界的制造能力
原创型的思维
第一性原理的思维
工程师的落地
还有受托人的精神
完全不被困难
坚定的毅力
在这刻就爆发出来
在几个月的时间
我们从一只手套都没有
变成了全世界最大的
这个口罩制造商
一天一一只
也是个神奇的过程
这个时候比亚迪和Berkshire合作
中国和美国互相的信任和背书
又在这一次发挥了巨大的媲美化
能够在这一点很短的时间里
基本上从消费者到各个州
到美国联邦政府
到欧洲的国家
所有的全球都在很短的时间
接受了比亚迪的产品
它的质量 它的细腻
也确确实实帮助了无数的人
也是验证了你刚才说的
你不断的去帮助别人
确实有好报
达人助己
真的是这样
活灵活现
在短短六个月里面
体现了灵敌尽神
真的是这样
在比亚迪做口罩之前
全中国的整个口罩产能
一天是两千万只
我们比亚迪三天出图纸
七天收散生产线
从五百万只一天开始
我们很快到了一个多月
就到了一亿只
是全中国所有口罩产能的五倍
而且为中国和全球的纽带关系
做出了巨大的贡献
也为中国的这次防御做出了巨大的贡献
也彰显了中国制造的能力和优势
也建立了品牌在海外
帮了人
那个时候全球的中国之外的生产能力
也是只有两千万
加在一起全球的生产力就是四千万
最后在六个月里
今天的比亚迪
已经是一个中国的世界冠军
但是比亚迪是一个充满着梦想的公司
我们正在从中国的世界冠军
要蜕变成全球的领袖
您觉得比亚迪还有什么样的路要走
还会遇到哪些困难和挑战
技术上
公司治理上
企业文化上
全球责任上等等
我相信也不会那么一蹴而就
所以我特别想听听您这位智者
从您对人类的文明史
对科技发展的进步和迭代
对价值的发现
给比亚迪再提提一些什么想法和建议
智者谈不上
我们一个真正伟大的企业
实际上是没有边界
它的发展也不会停止下来
增长也没有天花门
我们其实
虽然走了一条很长的路
但是还有更长的路要走
中国在这个节点上发展
也开始进入到一个新的台阶
各方面的元素都使得我们下面的
几十年的发展其实更值得期待
首先我们叫全球公司这个概念
Multinational Corporation
最早工业化的欧洲的国家
后来二战之后的美国国家
实现了真正虽然基于一个国家
但是商业在全球同时发展
那么现在这个节点上
中国公司开始具备了这样的机会
这样的能量
这样的能力
中国提供给这些公司最重要的条件
就是它是一个巨大的
单一的
大的市场
它又单一
又统一
从regulation上
然后又巨大
同时是市场
是一个开放型的
对全球开放型的市场
这些四个条件合在一起
就使得在这个市场里面的冠军
有机会在全球都成为冠军
而且它一定在当地化
成为当地经济发展的一部分
不仅仅是出口
所以这个时代是会出现
以中国为基础全球公司
中国籍的全球公司
比亚迪是这个浪潮里面
重要的一朵浪花
不是唯一的
当然
这个过程才刚刚开始
还有很长很长的路
要走可走
这是一个方面
另一个方面
中国经过四五十年的发展
我们也开始具备了
人才 技术 市场
各个方面
都到了一个创造力爆发的时代
就在这个时代里头
原创的技术 原创的产品
了不起的定义行业的企业
都会密集性的出现
在几乎所有的领域
所以在这个时代
对于一个没有边界的一个企业
能够用第一性原理来思考
公司未来的前进的企业
能够有工程师的文化
我们又有劳动力的红利
又有工程师的红利
又有技术的积累
所以它能够去迸发出的创造力
会更灿烂
所以在这个时候
比阿迪是非常幸运的
在这个时代
他就具备了声誉
具备了技术的储备
人才的储备
规模的优势
产品的领先
品牌的免疫度
所有这些都在一起
再加上我们的创学
还有公司的员工
仍然处在旺盛的
这个年龄段和经历
还在旺盛的时期
我认识王祖二十几年
他这个生活
没有发生过什么变化
依旧
仍然是从早一直到半夜
然后第二天重新开始
我们一起要在外面去旅行
尤其是团队去
一天最重要的会
永远是晚上11点
白天所有的工作做完了
11点又开始总结了
然后睡觉之后
第二天早上又开始
精力满满
动力满满
我们的边界还很遥远
增长还非常值得期待
而在这个时候
又是质量和技术爆发的时代
但是我们虽然在技术上常常领先
但是在精细化管理方面
其实又处在一个非常触及的阶段
要管理十几万的工程师
几十万甚至上百万的员工
很长的一个产品线
在多个国家
我们还要有好多好多的探索
才能够真正做到精细化的管理
才能真正做到以客户为中心
把产品真正的做精做细
还有上十万个专利
而且不断地在研发出新的方向
所以这些潜力要实现
它一直是不断地在扩大期权的过程中
所以它的内在价值一直在增长
所以这个是我们最看重的
我们作为投资人
你看我们拥有23年的时间
其中股价跌了50%以上
大概至少有七八次
一次跌了80%以上
每次涨的也快
但是涨的时候也可以很快
一年十倍的情况也出现过
所以在这个过程中
如果你是一个投机的心态
是很难真正享受到整个过程的
所以本分一点思考问题
无论是作为管理者还是作为投资人
挣自己应该挣的钱
你应该挣的钱实际上就是
公司本身内在价值不断地被实现
不断地增长
最后慢慢被认可时候的那一份
当然我们觉得也非常的幸运
这样的企业其实很少
如果大家企业都是永远是增长
这个世界我们就真的是
这书长到天上这个也不太可能
所以这样的企业是凤毛麟角
我们的幸运是在很早的时候
发现了这样一个了不起的企业
这样一个了不起的企业家
而且跟随着企业一起成长一起学习
在这个中间有所帮助
让我们更加心安理顿
您谦虚了
这是您的眼光和智慧挖掘
投资它是你认知的结果
就是您相信你才会投比亚迪
也感谢您对比亚迪包容
就像您写的这本书
您写的这个叫做
文明现代化价值投资与中国
也是我非常喜欢的一本书
因为这本书里面
你对人类文明的整个进化
以及现代科学的一个迭代
包括价值投资的哲学
你是做了一个系统性的描述
也是给我的人生
对我的人生包括投资
都有很多很多的启发
虽然现在的世界好像有点乱
现在也就网络名词叫
世界就是个草苔斑子
但是您又是乐观的
您对世界的统一大市场
您是长期认为
这是人类发展的必然结果
您也认为文明3.0
应该讲要持续为社会和世界
创造出它所需要的价值
这才是根本
我想您刚才的对于我提的问题
您的回答
应该用这个也能完美的阐述
只要比亚迪继续努力
持续为世界和人类创造
更好的更高的价值
那就是我们的使命
我们就能够去为世界文明做贡献
而不要去管这个世界
是怎么个草苔斑子
我们做好我们自己吧
刚才我说了那么多
王总不变的有非常多的特点
今天的比亚迪
又站在历史的一个新的舞台
假如说从过去的二十几年
你和王总的交流友谊
不变的有非常多
但是我又想请问一下
那王总变的又是哪一些呢
一定变了很多
对 我觉得王总身上
我觉得最让我很钦佩的特质
就是他这个学习的能力
持续学习的能力
所以学习本身
也是一个学习了学习的方法之后
他的学习就开始以辅力的形式
不断地在前进
真心地体会到
在过去的二十几年的
王总对于商业的那些
对不同技术的理解
对于实现长期目标短期的量化
对于管理这个庞大
越来越增加的员工和资产
还有市场面临的各种各样
复杂的问题
都有个惊人的变化
因为这个就是福利的力量
但是不仅仅是王总
我们这个公司的高管的团队
大家还在争刺里面
我们还在坚持
还在努力
我们下一代更年轻的
这个组织本身
慢慢地就幻化成一个学习的组织
应该说还没有完全的
完全地完成这个过程
我们还要学习的还有很多很多
因为我们增长的这个速度
尤其是在快速增长的时候
它一定会产生很多很多新的问题
我们过去这五年的经验
其实也不可能永远的复制
这个是不是这个盘整
这些都是必然的
所以如果说我们对未来
有一个比较现实的期待的话
我们要该犯的错误
新的错误
我们需要的盘整
这都是必然的
也没什么大不了
这个过去的这些经验
让我们更加有信心
遇到不同的问题
和不同的挑战的时候
就真正地一步一步地去应对它
每个你走很长很长的路
其实都是左脚在前
右脚在前
左脚在前
一步一步都是这样走的
关键是不停地走
不停地走就能走得很远
同时坚定地相信走的方向
我的想法呢
是基于理性和常识的乐观
仍然是人类最好的选择
但是要基于理性
基于常识
在这个基础上建立了乐观主义
是让我们能够不断走下去的动力
我们过去的印记帮我们更加有信心
我们的不断的学习
让我们具备更多的理性
更多的常识
更明确的方向
但是坚定的脚印
仍然是通向成功唯一的办法
所以我希望还能够看到
跟比亚迪一起再走一场长远的道路
作为一路相伴的挚友伙伴
我想您给比亚迪下一个30年
最真挚的祝福或者期待
我已经讲过了
我没有什么特别的
我也不是一个特殊人
我也没有什么提出的问题
每天一步一个脚印就可以
不需要去想的那么远
每天踏踏实实的向前走
芒哥先生一个话我很喜欢
每天早晨醒来的时候
比昨天的都更聪明一点
学习更多一点就可以了
每天如此
福利的力量是强大无比的
外面的盘整可以很多
但是内在的进步
是我们自己都能够感受到的
我们只要每天都能够比前一天
稍稍的学习多一点
我们就可以走很远很远的道路
所以这种态度
是一个企业能够去长久走下去
我们要不仅是个人
把整个企业打造成这样的学习机器
能够不断以福利的方式去前进
我们就能走很远
这是送给比亚迪的
也是送给我的
我感谢能够今天这一个多小时的交流
也感谢一直以来你给我的
精神上的一些鼓励和支持
我希望以后多有机会能向您请教
也希望您一直陪伴着比亚迪
然后我们一直一起变得每天
比每天变得好一点
聪明一点
是的
非常感谢
我作为武东真的是对于所有的比亚迪员工
无论是今天的还是过去的还是未来的
心存感激之心
非常非常的感谢
再次谢谢吕总